25 months six waves and several vaccines
later many canadians have gotten used to
living with covet 19. i'm not worried as
much as before we are going in a
positive direction i think we need to
embrace that i wouldn't particularly say
scared but like
i'd say realistically cautious
an ipso study surveyed over 1500
canadians and found the fear of
contracting covet 19 is trending
downward from 56
in january of this year to 44
in april infectious diseases researcher
matthew miller says canadians are ready
to live with the virus
we're probably past the phase of really
severe lockdown if a more pathogenic
virus were to emerge meaning a variant
that causes more severe severe illness
there will be some ability to attenuate
that with vaccines and hopefully with
these antivirals that are now available
miller says covet 19 and its waves won't
be disappearing from canada anytime soon
we'll just develop better tools to
tackle its severity more tailored
recommendations depending on the
personal risk factors update the vaccine
so that they're a better match for the
variance the hope is as we move through
the summer um we'll see the current wave
uh tone down and as we move into fall
and winter we'll see case rates climb
again and so it would be great if a we
had updated vaccines but also approval
of vaccines for younger children
charming somani global news